what's going on guys welcome back to
another ATX tutorial miniseries within
our Python mathematics and stock
indicators tutorial series where we left
off we've been working on this ATX here
we got the eyes calculated now since as
a part of the directional movement
system and now we actually want to
calculate the ATX line itself so now
that we have the stuff that we need for
that line we're going to go and define
ATX and let's do it
so posit to di- VI equals calc D eyes
didn't do it this already calls all the
functions that we need within it with
all the variables and all that so that
will return this PDI's ND eyes so that's
gonna return what we want now just for
the sake of debugging print lend
positive the I print blend negative di
and then finally print when date and
here's what we got to do 1 : why do we
have to do 1 : rather than one company
because very early on we were only
starting with the second day's prices
because we wanted to consider
yesterday's so that's why now we have to
be considering only date 1 : when we go
to plot it will have to remember that
otherwise X&Y won't match up
continuing on X X X I knew we were gonna
hit equals 0 then D X s equals empty
right
we just can't cut well direction yeah
that's gonna work this is actually the
directional thing and then when we get
to the actual average directional when
we apply the exponential moving average
that's when we'll call it ATX so we'll
keep that round so Wow xxx is less than
the length of it dates 1 : so everything
except for that first value
d x equals 100 times this this one's a
little bit longer of an equation so
first it's 100 times something right and
within there just to make will use
spaces to make it somewhat easier read
the first thing is the absolute value of
absolute value of positive di and that X
X X variable minus the negative D I xx X
variable then we're going to do that
divide it I just hit enter you don't
have to hit enter but if you want to
copy everything hit enter and it'll come
down in here and it'll still work out
mathematically it just makes it easier
to read and it keeps it on my screen
divided by more parenthesis and within
those positive di xxx plus negative di
xx x done now let's look at what we just
did so this is what we put in the last
video if we come to the ADX calculation
what we've just done is basically the
hundred times this part here and now we
just have to apply the exponential
moving average to this stuff because
really a hundred times all that's there
to do is move the decimal point right so
that can be really applied at just about
any time it could be applied to as long
as you're applying it you know to any of
the objects within this mathematical
calculation it's okay so anyway that's
what we've done we've just let's simply
left out the 14 EMA of all this stuff
but the 14 EMA times a 100 or the 14 AME
of this stuff times 100 is identical so
now let's go ahead and do that so this
gives us DX and so all we really have to
do at this
is a pendant so DX s startup and DX done
X X X plus equals 1 done come out of
that while loop print the Len of the
excess so debugging purposes something
goes wrong ad X now it was the expert
moving average o D X s with a 14 day
window
print Len ATX oops didn't me to get rid
of that print when we'll just do the
full date now again just since we
already did print out date minus 1 and
we're done so let's now all we have to
do is just call a DX to run all of this
stuff so now let's go ahead and just
come down you call a DX and now for the
moment of truth to see if this whole
program has any errors go ahead press f5
we'll see what happens no syntax xx
reference that's capital X X so I
already know the issue is all mine or
lowercase X X striking okay so what we
got here is what if I 105 105 good and
then we printed date just to show you
the full length of data is on a 6 but
we're looking for 105 which is why we
have to do day 1 so now a DX print Len
AAT X let's go ahead and print the ad X
so we can actually see it and that is
without outside of the while loop so
we'll just see it once so here is our
official a DX fits perfectly into our
window ok so that's cool yeah we've got
that all set now a lot of times people
use xx as like the crossover line but as
you can see I mean we all a lotta 20s
that have happened here but anyway just
keep that in mind so we've got ATX now
looks good
we've got I guess we haven't really seen
the plus di and minus di we could I
think print those out though yeah we can
print positive di- yeah so we can just
I'll just print them out just just for
kicks print positive di print
negative di so they are here looks about
right for positive and negative di these
are kind of than like it you just know
that it should be within the range of
maybe like a 1 to a 50 or something like
that and you definitely don't want to
see negatives here because it is all of
these are strength indicators so you
can't have really I think zero is the
absolute minimum you could possibly have
in any of these so anyway close that we
are not ready to port this over to our
charting application and get it up on
the graph so in the next video
that's exactly what we'll be doing so if
that sounds interesting to you guys
continue on in the next video as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support the subscriptions and until next
time